- [Wanda] When you put on
a hat, it gives you height,
and it gives you power.
- [Evetta] For us, church
hats are not just hats.
They are crowns, and
when a woman puts one on,
she becomes a queen.
(upbeat music)
(funky music)
- My name is Evetta Petty.
- I'm Kathy Anderson.
- And I am Wanda Chambers.
We've been making hats
for more than 20 years.
- A church hat is a very special hat.
Especially in the African
American community.
As a child growing up in
the south, in the 60s,
we always wore hats.
Sunday is the one day,
historically, that we had a chance,
and we step out in our Sunday best.
(upbeat music)
- I don't believe that church
hats are a thing of the past.
I have noticed that the
younger generation is taking
on the tradition of wearing hats.
It makes me happy to see
a younger woman with a hat
on her head because I know
that she's still carrying
on the tradition.
(upbeat music)
- I come from a long line
of church hat wearing women.
Everyone wore a hat.
It was a parade, it was
colors, it was magic.
- When you go to church and
you step in, and you see all
of your sisters wear hats on,
we all be eyeing each other
and under our breaths
saying, boy, that's a
really gorgeous hat.
So it's wonderful to be in
a room filled with women
with hats on.
And each one of us look absolutely amazing
in our own right.
(upbeat music)